what the [ __ ] is the difference between
peeing in the shower and using your
toilet peeing in the shower come on
admit it you've done it have you filthy
or is it look I don't know it's not my
call but I think we owe it to ourselves
to talk about it
so with that in mind we've brought
people here from both sides of the issue
to argue their cases peeing in the
shower it's debatable I'm Chris and I'm
for peeing in the shower I'm against
peeing in the shower I pee in the shower
I for obvious reasons do not pee in the
shower
you shouldn't pee in your bathtub or
your shower it's all pipes you're
literally in the cleanest place you can
be you've got soap if you're really that
afraid of their own pee I can see what
your fingers playing to okay it's an
argument of somebody who isn't
comfortable with themselves I'm just
afraid of being a human being I think
you're trying not to be drought save
water there are kids all over the world
that would be happy to take a shower in
your pee or you're in pump your pee you
just said you think children desire your
piss to roll around in are you listening
to yourself
you really want to save the environment
you Green Peace hippie you think the
three gallons one two three gallons
you're saving on that flesh is making
the difference that California needs
every little bit helps keep well we can
all pretend we care about pennies but
pennies are worthless Colin it's all
going down the same place anyways do you
take a [ __ ] in the shower it's pipes
like that's literally your argument no
it won't it won't go down and they will
eventually with water if you sprayed it
enough no literally the same train of
thought you don't go to a public park
and pee on the water fountain it gets
all pipes Colin the problem with that is
that you were exposing your penis in
public what if I put a little like bowl
over my penis [ __ ] is not a comparable
thing the comparable thing that you
could have said which he didn't would be
like would you put semen in the shower
and my answer is yes for women it's
better to pee in the shower because you
don't have to worry about
paper getting in your lady bits because
that's how UTIs get well what about baby
wipes
why don't use a baby wipe okay rich guy
rich guy I believe urine is sterile and
it's something that you can literally
drink have you drinkin your own I have
never been stranded on a deserted island
but if I did I would yeah I would too
but I would it's not like in everyday
life every morning I'm gonna take a swig
of my own piss you weirdo what are you
doing doesn't pee in pools either no I
love peeing pool I don't have exclusive
rights to my shower I share my shower
with my girlfriend
I don't want to do that to her what are
you doing to her I'm forcing her to try
to get clean in a misty aroma of my
urine I wish I had a mop in there to mop
up the disgusting mess that is my own
urine it sounds like something is up
with your pee if it's that normally I'm
not like pissing all over myself are
like peeing all over the bathtub I'm
peeing into a drain this is an argument
about your marksmanship which I'm sure
is no doubt great have you been a
relationship and peeing with the door
open in front of someone yes I shouldn't
find uh someone with the door open we
all have but my point is is that you
won't do it in the shower you're too
good for that it's going on their feet
if you like spray I'm not saying my dick
is a shotgun glass but I'm saying that
when I'm peeing into a stream of water
hitting it there's ricochet scenarios
other people use washing machines that
have been filled with your clothes full
of your poop stained underwear
so are you guys whooping are you doing
in your underwear Collin [ __ ]
everybody's underwear has had a poop
stain in it at some point you can't see
it sometimes there's just become a turd
equal matter on everything you're not
clean once a week perhaps the lies
there's rules made to pee while you are
in the shower and you go [ __ ] I have to
pee at the very beginning of the shower
I wrap it up like an adult fry myself up
in a condom on lip you rock it up yeah
I'm gonna put a condom on my dick and
peeing into make a giant water balloon
like no no we're doing a prize have you
made that up do you shower before sex no
of course not
I didn't get that dead why is that
because you said you don't want to get
your girlfriend dirty would you ever
stick your foot in in inside the toilet
maybe if I dropped a necklace down there
Oh how's your necklace getting in there
oops no problem going down there your
hands all drip and piss when you got
your necklace on you don't even wipe it
off do your let's also keep in mind that
people pee in the shower aren't always
dudes
I mean I've watched girls pee before and
why it's definitely more of like a
firehose situation right it's like that
I'm simply letting it fall down my
thighs into the drain oh sure Queen feet
Oh piss on
freedom relaxation time management I
think that as a human you shouldn't do
that lazy lazy lazy you shame yourself I
am with the ninety nine percent here
ninety nine percent of people don't piss
in the shower I'm comfortable with this
[ __ ] filled air that we breathe every
day you live your life going I live mine
[Music]
what do you think about catheters who
like recreationally sure
[Music]